[Musique]
on est tous
ensemble une grande
aventure l'asion de voir ce que la vie n
[Musique]
réserve que ça fait pe doute çaut coup
non on va t
passer c'est quoi cet endroit estètement
perdu
c'est pas votre
mère on voudrait aller en
[Musique]
jamaïqueit comment
tu que vous vous
la alors voilà donc
la il y a que moi qui entend la
CR
[Musique]
qui e une migration c'est surtout une
aventure il vient de se passer quoi je
sais pas mais tu es dans la
[Musique]
mouise qu'est-ce que c'est que ça canard
à l'or c'est quoi un canard à
l'orange c'est toi avec des
oranges j'ai envie qu'on aille découvrir
le
monde
[Musique]
face au
danger on ne fuit surtout pas
[Musique]
M nous irons au bout de cette folle et
merveilleuse
[Musique]
aventure il ont tellement ador
ah je devrais peut-être vous manger mon
plaisante
ou peut-être pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hein